Hey, good afternoon.
Hello, how are you doing?
Doing pretty good, how about you?
Good, good, good. Hey, sorry, I'm going to have to take this call from my vehicle. I had to run and meet my sister, so I apologize for not being on video. So
No problem. Or I think you want to maybe suggest any other time if it is not a good time.
No, no, it works now. If that's good, I think we can definitely talk through.
if there's anything that comes up for you, you know, that you had on your agenda. I just, you know, I just want to keep keep moving forward with what we've done with Abel and, you know, Alberto and Vikas. We had a small little issue with Vikas this week. It was nothing that he did, but it was our system was configured to send out
I.
tickets to our customer on a board that shouldn't have. And anyway, he, it was just a perfect storm of like, oh man, felt bad for that whole situation because it was basically the customer kind of freaked out because, you know, it was basically all of our security alerts, you know, and
And it was false positives. You know, it's stuff that, you know, 99.9% of the world would be fine, but it was just for this one specific customer. They're already kind of amped up, you know, with what they're doing and where they're at in their world. So yeah, it was it was it was an interesting
Mhm.
couple days there where, you know, you're just like, oh man, how did we have that board still enabled, you know, to send emails. So, but anyway.
Okay.
Yeah, I think you should.
But yeah, nothing, no, no take, yeah, no takeaways at all from that. It was more just keep you informed on kind of behind the scenes of what we're doing on that one. So.
Kip.
No, no, thank you. Thank you for the update. How about Alberto? How is doing?
Yeah, doing well. I think, you know, as far as one of the big challenges that I've given him, you know, is, you know, getting your time entered, you know, it's one of the major components that I'm fighting right now is our utilization is low. And I need to make sure that we're all, you know, working to make sure, because I know people are working on things and that they're
but we need to make sure everybody's entering their time and doing it extremely regularly. Like it's got to be something that's very consistent and not like, you know, just one of the, because the challenge that we have is now we're, you know, we were bought out by a private equity company, right? And
they're all about the numbers, you know, and so it's like, no longer can I just say, no, we're busy, you know, it's like, no, we actually have to show, you know, that we're busy and, you know, all the numbers need to add up, you know, kind of thing. So, but
Right.
No, no, thank you for highlighting this. I think I do remember from our previous service call, that is the main focus of this entire month to make sure they are aligned with us and Alberto especially. So I do see earlier, you know, you were there, everything was on track.
Because you know them right better than data prize, what all they doing, what all the capability they have, but, and again, end of the day, numbers matter, no matter how, what, what do you do if the number shows less, does not, you know, going to give an explanation to that that this engineer or these are.
Yu.
Yeah.
from the people that working with you are delivering that much. So my focus was on that side. I have scheduled call every day with both, right? Because if I am just kind of comparing the numbers for last six months, so if I talk about, right, because whenever the conversation had with you, it's very transparent and the honest conversation. So.
Okay.
We talk about, you know, Alberto, Vikas, so overall 40, 45%, that's what the number look like, right? If I go for the three month data and four month data. So that's what I specific ask them, though, the number, whatever was earlier, it was okay, but now it's not okay. 70% that.
Right.
80% that ITBD had planned.
Yeah, and that's what I'm having conversations with all of our, all of our, you know, engineers because the way it has been is no longer the way it's going to be or the way it is now. And I think that advice is perfect of now it's 70 and it's...
In my mind, utilization is not all billable work. And we just need to capture our work so I can tell the story, you know, and that's that is such a key part of what we're doing for sure. So, but.
Exactly.
I agree with your plan and I have aligned them right to make sure that anything that they're doing, whether it is online, offline, they're doing board review, they're doing ticket scrub or anything, make sure you enter that time. So at least the billable that I mean just for them.
Yes, yep.
80% we plan and at least the number they need to achieve out of 80, 70% should be billable. Rest 10 or 15% should be their meeting, their hurdles, their offline work they are doing. So those times should go on that side, but 70% completely customer facing that we need.
Yu.
Yep, no, I, I...
Because if tomorrow, not as an ITBD, but even if Tim is going to tell data price, so these are the focus that we have, this is how much they are delivering, but he's going to show the numbers, right? He cannot going to represent you there, right? But number matters. If number shows 30%, 40%, so.
It will be a question that the task or the bill level which 40, 50% combining 2 engineer and that one can fulfill that, right? Then why do we need two?
Right, right, right.
So there's a risk factor on that side. So yeah, I have aligned them right. I'm keeping close eye every day. Make sure they're entering time. If they don't have tickets, they update you, Marky, to make sure you get extra tasks. If there is no ticket alert, tickets that probably.
They can handle, they can work on those alert ticket. So I think I mean, you're an announcer, but I probably have few clarity things which I probably need. Maybe later we probably can set up a 10, 15 minute call. That is just related to, so what I'm doing the recent practice for last two weeks.
Yeah.
I'm reviewing their tickets and everything on their board. How many ticket they have, how many ticket they are closing, what is the ticket status, how they are putting notes. So a few things which I noticed, probably they need some clarification on that. The one thing probably I want to highlight since you're here. So example, yesterday I was reviewing the board for tickets for both.
Mhm.
Right.
So ticket disposition, which mean the ticket status, like if they are working on the ticket, they put the status on in progress. If the ticket is waiting for customer, they're putting ticket status customer or scheduled, right? But few ticket I found where like the ticket status is in progress.
Yeah, perfect. Yep, yep.
But in actual nodes, the ticket is waiting for a customer, waiting for, or maybe the ticket is already escalated to someone.
Oh, okay. Yeah. No, I think that's good of, yeah, keep that status as accurate as possible. No, I think that's.
So.
Because.
Mick.
So, because unexpected I even suddenly asked to share the skin, then I saw, oh, Alberto, how you're working on 6 ticket I saw on in progress. Is it not possible if someone see the board, they'll see, oh, is working on six ticket? Then, and then I checked that only one ticket there was, he was actually working, but rest.
The status was not right. Second thing I probably had discussion with Vikas with the point that you raised about whenever you put in notes in the tickets, everyone using AI, right? But again, we are humans, so don't copy paste everything from directly from ChatGPT or Claude and put on the notes, right?
Mm.
Yeah, right, right.
Convert into your own human language, mention it, take help, but that's a few observations that I, you know, highlighted with them, so they're they're aligned.
No, that's great. Yeah, great advice, great advice. And you know, and that's the thing, you know, I don't mind the full, you know, data drop from, you know, chat or, you know, the Claude side of things, but it is, you know, just making sure that if it does go to a customer, that's, you know, if you're doing internal notes, totally fine. Like, I don't care.
Right.
right, but if you're doing customer facing, because that's even some of the, like, some of their auto responses, hey, I've been assigned your ticket, kind of speaking in not so formal language. It's that fine line, right, of like, still being human, but not robotic, you know, figuring out what that, you know, that fine line is. And I think those are things that we can.
Yeah.
constantly improve on, you know, from, you know, just the interactions with the customers and how important those are. So.
No, no, I do remember you when you shared, I think a few months back, that data price has a quality team who audit the tickets, right? So if anyone audit or check those ticket right, it will not give a good impression. So I think the plan that I have, because as of now, I call them, connect with them, because I know they are busy.
But.
Right, right.
So it's not giving me enough time to check the tickets and everything. So I think I need your support if possible to the way other our partner does. They have given for the manager a separate access for the connect ways for like that way they have like Alberto enable has the credential for a connect way. So that is separate.
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
for me where I can log in, can review their board, can check their ticket without interrupting them and you know going on call and individually scrubbing individual ticket. So those kind of conditional can set for me.
Brian.
Wonder.
Yeah, no, I definitely, let me, yeah, let me talk to Mike of what, because I'm not sure if there's a different role that I can give you or, you know, just from an account standpoint, what that looks like. But let me do some investigation on that and see if I can get that set up for you. Because that'll, the more eyes and ears and like coaching that I can get to, you know, like.
Yeah, I think.
Real-time coaching is going to make everybody better, you know, so totally, totally agree.
Yeah, yeah, that's because the time I am spending with them, what happened because when I call, they are on call with you for next 30, so I don't want to be if there is in a waiting call or customer appointment. So they should, you know, focused on my part and missed on the other side. So if I have the separate credential, I can definitely.
Right.
log in my own time convenience and review their ticket then share the feedback with them.
Yep, no, I agree. So let me, yeah, I'll take that as my takeaway for today for sure. So.
Yeah, I mean, you can shoot me an email or credential and everything. And I think last one about Abel. I know he's doing a really fantastic job. So, and again, thank you so much for the last email that you sent.
But.
Okay. Yep.
Yeah, and I, well, and I feel I...
Yeah, no, I feel like I've kind of let him down on, you know, just again, getting that, you know, he's done such a fantastic job with all the constraints and all the kind of getting where we're at right now. Now we're in a spot where I'm stuck with, I've got to get two meetings set up. And that's my goal today is to get two meetings set up, one with our internal
expert who is, he's pretty much an application developer because I want him to look at it and look through it one final time and then be for, and that's what Abel and I were going to do on Monday, but he got pulled into kind of a security meeting where he had to, he wasn't able to meet with us.
So, but trying to find time on that guy's calendar is like trying to find a miracle. Like he is just so busy. So I'm going to get him scheduled, but then that follows up with, I need to get this application hosted so that we can start moving to that next version, you know, of what we're trying to do. Because what we have right now is so incredible and will help us immensely.
But it's the I need to get it so that I can make up part of my workflow, you know, of what I'm doing. So.
No, I agree with that. So he's really happy and motivated, you know, the appreciation that you get. So when you forward that email, you get appreciation from Kam and Sunny. The entire leadership really appreciate it. So I think the last week he was the AI innovator engineer who gave the demo.
But...
That's awesome.
Oh, awesome. Oh, that's great. Okay.
to the entire ITBD employee state of the company meeting that we had. So he was showing how much wonderful work that he is doing, what all innovation that he has done, and what all idea, I guess. So you get that.
Ohh my gosh, wow.
That's awesome.
That is so cool. Well, here's the, hey, I need to make sure he's not promoted so much that he has to leave our company, you know, so, you know, so we need to make sure we don't, no, I'm kidding. No, that's super cool because he definitely has that motivation that's hard to teach, you know, like you either have it or you don't, you know, and so having someone who gets
No.
Yeah.
You know, and that's why I think we make such a great team because I just keep coming up with new ideas, new, you know, and he's like, oh, I can do that. I can do that, you know, and it's like, all right, I like this, you know, so I am so enjoying it because it gives me kind of like that potential outlook for where we're heading is in such a great spot for
Not that we're not in, you know, we're in challenging times. Like I think we all know that the markets and all the, you know, everybody's looking at every penny, you know, being spent, right? So, so I think for us is making sure that what we're doing is helping drive and find those revenue bleeds, you know, that we can really capitalize on for sure. So,
Yeah.
Correct.
Well, that makes me excited that he was, he got kudos from the heads of IT by Design. That's really cool. Like just from a, you know, more than just outside of our group, you know, like this guy is really good. So I definitely enjoy working with him a lot. So.
Yes.
Yeah, and he has been nominated for, I was just sharing the, with him just a while ago, he has nominated the superstar of this quarter. So we have like a recognition, a reward program every quarter for the entire company wise. So where he has been selected for the superstar of this particular quarter.
Ohh, that's awesome.
That is, that it will keep, yeah, keep me updated on that, because I would love to spread that to to the rest of the, you know, to the our, especially our team, you know, like I just, I love that, you know, because everybody looks up to them for, you know, not only being, you know, just incredible, you know, but just super talented, like you just know those people, you know, who...
who don't give up when they run into a, you know, they find the door or they make a door, you know, to figure out how to get through the next step. So, but...
No, I get it.
Yeah.
Great, I think we're good. I mean, I checked for all, right? And I shared what plan I have for all three of them. So again, the team channel that I already opened, right? So since our call is in monthly, but if you find anything that need to discuss before, just one ping on the team channel, I can call you and we can discuss. So no need to wait for.
That's.
Okay.
Perfect.
So, rest, and yeah, so the other thing which probably I will ask them to follow up and check with you and Marky 2 to make sure they are aligned about the ticket hygienic and ticket quality, so they follow the standard that every MSP follow, you know, avoid any any mistake or anything.
Yeah, yeah.
No.
No, that's great.
Right, I think we're we're good. Yeah, I'll.
Well, thank you for your time. Yeah, yeah. No, thank you. I appreciate it, man.
Thank you so much again, Tim. Take care. Have a good weekend then. Thank you. You too. Bye.
Yep. All right. Have a good one. You too. Bye bye.